Hi, everybody.
Let's talk about digital employees, or digeys.
I'm Leslie Chau with IBM Automation.
What is a digital employee?
What can it do for you?
And what value does it bring to the human workforce?
Let's start by looking at an example.
I'd like you to meet Cassie.
Cassie is a recruiter.
She helps people like Ava.
Ava is a manager.
And Ava's looking to hire for her team.
Cassie helps Ava with the end-to-end hiring process.
Among other things that she does, she helps Ava look for candidates for her job.
Her typical workflow looks something like this.
She starts by using LinkedIn recruiter to search for and find the right candidates for the job.
She then goes through the search results and finds matching candidates that are qualified for the job.
She then messages these candidates and schedules a screening interview
to make sure that they are the right match for Ava.
And then finally, when she has the right list of short-listed candidates,
she compiles that list into a spreadsheet
so that Ava can then proceed to the next step.
Now, Cassie. She wants to spend more of her time doing this.
These are higher value tasks, like reviewing resumes or thoughtfully preparing for the screening interview
so that she can have a best set of candidates for Ava.
She also knows that as a recruiter, this is where she can really flex her skills.
But instead, she spends most of her day on manual and repetitive tasks.
These are things like combing through a list of candidates in the search results.
Later in the process, when she's come up with the shortlist of candidates,
she spends a lot of her time copy/pasting.
She copy/pastes information from LinkedIn into the spreadsheet
to prepare that for Ava to review.
She also spends a lot of her time in administrative tasks like messaging Ava,
messaging the candidates, scheduling time with the candidates.
Now, wouldn't it be great if Cassie had her own personal helper
that can help her do these manual tasks?
So that she can focus on some of these more higher value tasks
that really require, you know, the human skills and the intuition and the analytics.
This is where the digital employee comes in.
I'd like you to meet HenRy.
Henry as an HR digital employee and Cassie's new sidekick.
The digital employees have three main functions.
First, it can interact with the world around it.
It can interact with Cassie.
Second, it has AI and it can interpret what is being asked to do.
And finally it can do work.
But just like human employees, digital employees have a set of job skills.
For digital employees,
these are essentially API calls and software robotics.
These skills help the digital employee interact with systems
such as LinkedIn and spreadsheets on behalf of Cassie.
So that all Cassi has to do is ask.
Cassie asks HenRy to do something
and HenRy, in turn, uses his AI to interpret what that ask is
and then match it to the skills that it has to do the work for Cassie.
In this example, Cassie can simply ask HenRy to do the search for the candidates in LinkedIn.
Now HenRy can interpret that and quickly match it to the LinkedIn skill that it has.
So it will call the LinkedIn API to do the search.
It can even go one step further and message the right candidates
and schedule a time for Cassie to have the screening interviews with the candidates.
Later on the process, Cassie can ask HenRy to take the short-listed candidates and compiled them into lists in the spreadsheet.
HenRy will interpret that and match it to its spreadsheet skill.
It will manually copy/paste each and every row of the short lists into the spreadsheet
and can even go and signal to Ava when that list is ready for her to review.
This was a very simple example, but it shows you how a digital employee can help Cassie save hours of time of manual work.
Now Cassie can focus some more of her attention on higher value work
and where she can spend more of her time now reviewing resumes
and thoughtfully preparing for those interviews so that she can come up with a better list of candidates for Ava.
She can even start differentiating herself now from her peers
by writing thoughtful recommendations to Ava so Ava can make a better decision and the next steps.
This was a quick overview of digital employees.
If you would like to learn more about digital employees such as how you actually build one,
be sure to smash that "Subscribe" button.
If you liked the video or have a question or comment,
be sure to hit that "Like" button and leave your comment in the comments section.
Thank you so much for your time.